[Music]
you know that game would you rather
would you rather have two foam arms or
be constantly followed everywhere by
tiny ducklings my feelings about privacy
and personal data on my smartphone kind
of remind me of this game would I rather
give up my smartphone or agree to carry
around a bunch of little spies my pocket
this is my Android I've downloaded
fifty-seven apps Facebook whatsapp The
Guardian
Fitbit Twitter Spotify when I download
an app I have to accept the Terms of
Service but I rarely read them to find
out which apps are tracking me I
installed another app it warns me if
data is shared without my knowledge
according to that app 30 of the 57
applications I downloaded access data
that concerns my private life for
example social networks accessed my
contacts to suggest me friends without
this data the application wouldn't
really work sometimes it's really
surprising as far as I know my
flashlight doesn't mean my personal data
to function but it does access my UDID
that stands for unique device
identifiers which every phone is given
when it's manufactured this UDID like
you is unique in the world
my flashlight transmits it to
advertisers and they use it like a
browser cookie tracking my UDID
lets them learn my mobile habits and
send me targeted advertisements right
now I'm at a cafe where I live that fact
is shared with huge advertising
companies that collect millions of
smartphone user profiles
we asked Harlow Holmes to explain how
the apps go about collecting our data
apps worker and of course Android and
iOS and windows phones and blackberries
they all have slightly different ways of
doing it but ultimately they're what are
called permissions and these permissions
if you grant them allow a specific app
access to what's called an API it's kind
of like a door you want to open the door
to the contacts you ask the API and it
gives you what you need Angry Birds was
one such app that in addition to you
know asking for access to the stuff that
we'd expect such as the gyroscope in
order for you to play the game they also
asked for access to your contacts and by
giving them that you're allowing them to
go into your phone and to make use in
whatever way that they deem fit of the
people that you know and how they can be
contacted that same thing that we're
afraid of of political actors making use
of our contacts just to understand
exactly who's connected to whom and how
and when and possibly why is also used
by advertisers in order to sell us more
products in order to determine who among
your friends has the most influence that
kind of a thing it's a matter of who's
asking the question and why are they
asking this question and then there's
the data which is collected based on my
whereabouts in the next video we'll
learn why my geolocation is a goldmine
of data this is me at works at home at
the dentist on vacation at the park in
my history I can find all of the places
I've been in the last few days